has also been very close to my heart my
cabinet has always been gender balanced
this Parliament legislated for free
period products and strengthened the law
on domestic abuse
unless tangibly perhaps but just as
important no girl in our country now has
any doubt that a woman can hold the
highest office in the land
I heard a phrase the other day that
really struck a chord with me when women
lift girls rise I've tried his first
minister to put that into practice and I
will continue to do so for the rest of
my life
setting officer there are countless
people who have supported me along the
way today I want to see a heartfelt
thank you to just some of them
firstly to my family
nothing absolutely nothing would be
possible without the love and support
you give me daily
to my extended family the SNP
the party I joined at 16 when on a good
day we would hit 12 in their opinion
polls
we've come such a long way together as a
team let us keep going serving Scotland
together as a team
to my colleagues here in Hollywood in
SNP parliamentary groups past and
present and to the central office staff
who support us
to all of my ministerial colleagues over
the years
and especially to John Sweeney the best
Deputy first Minister and the best
friend I could have wished for on this
journey
to our staff in part HQ who have built a
formidable campaign operation enabling
us to win 14 national elections since
2007. to all those who have worked in my
constituency office and particular to my
current team Paul Leinster Caroline
Scott Mary Hunter Carolyn mcconville
Irfan Rabbani and Nikita Bassey you have
had my back throughout and you work
tirelessly every single day to help me
represent the people of Glasgow South
Side
and to my constituency party and to my
constituents thank you so much for
putting your trust in me time and again
to my special advisors you have given
your all to me and to the cause of
building a better country you've been
led by two outstanding Chiefs of Staff
Liz Lloyd and Colin McAllister
to our partners in the Scottish green
party I am very proud of the boot house
agreement thank you for joining us in
government
and to our brilliant Civil Service
Scotland is so fortunate in the
Integrity impartiality and
professionalism of our civil servants
and I am privileged to have been served
by some of the very best I thank each
and everyone but let me make special
mention of those who have served in my
policy unit and in my fmq team the
latter especially on Wednesday evenings
and Thursday mornings really do have the
worst job in government
the avoidance of Doubt presiding officer
the good answers have always been down
to them the bad have been all meat
finally I want to thank from the bottom
of my heart three groups of people who
because of the nature of the jobs they
do have probably spent more time with me
over these years than with their
families at least I'm sure that is how
it has felt so to my security team thank
you for keeping me safe
to the wonderful boot house staff thank
you for always making me feel at home
and to every private secretary diary
secretary correspondent secretary to the
visits and events team to the
communications and Camera teams to
everyone in my private office who has
supported me over 16 years in government
thank you for keeping me going
obviously I can't name everyone as much
as I'd love to but there are a few I do
want to mention
my longest serving principal private
secretary John Summers and the current
incumbent Chris Mackey
and last but not least three very
special people who individually and
collectively have been with me for
almost all of my time as first minister
three people who were the core of my
team during covet coming into the office
While others stayed at home to give me
the support I needed to do my job
Nicola Dove Patrick krula and Gary McGee
you three will never know how much your
care kindness and humor have sustained
me over these years and I am so going to
miss you
planning officer as I come to the end of
my last speech here as first Minister
some final reflections
to you
I am sure you're hoping for a new first
Minister whose answers on a Thursday
lunch time are not quite as long-winded
as mine
thank you for your patience
to my colleagues across this chamber
robust debate and holding government to
account are the Hallmarks of what we do
in here that is as it should be and let
me thank those in other parties for that
but maybe just maybe we might
actually enhance our democracy
have occasionally we all of us treated
each other with kindness too if we
remembered that we are opponent not
enemies
and to my successor
next week we will find out whose
portrait will go alongside mine on the
stairwell of boot house
subject to this chamber's approval it
will either be Scotland's second female
first minister or the first from a
minority ethnic background
either way that will send the very
powerful message that this the highest
office in the land is one that any young
person in Scotland can aspire to
never forget that every day in this
office is an opportunity
to make something better for someone
somewhere in Scotland do not shy away
from the big challenges or difficult
debates you won't get everything right
but it is always better to aim high and
fall short than not try at all
and always draw strength energy and
wisdom from the people of this wonderful
country
and it is now to the people of Scotland
all of you whether you voted for me or
not that I reserve my final words from
the seat
thank you so much for placing your trust
in me
words will never
adequately convey the Gratitude and they
all I hold in my heart
for the opportunity I have had to serve
as your first minister
it truly has been the privilege of my
lifetime and with these words presiding
officer I draw it to a close
thank you
from Nicola sturgeon as Scotland's first
minister
Minister I will now call on other
members to respond